et le tournoi de plaisir si clôturé ce
dimanche 24 septembre par la finale du
tableau masculin le français antoine
wang 21 ans tête de série numéro 6 a
remporté la finale contre le hollandais
sijsling issu des qualifications après
avoir perdu le premier set 4 à 6 le
sportif tricolore remporte les deux sets
suivants 6 3 6 4
à match à l'image de cette 27e édition
qui a été très disputée sur les courts
de plaisir on écoute le président du
club charles jordan au micro de tv 78 je
veux pas commencer à citer les noms mais
vous avez en une finale exceptionnelle
avec le néerlandais qui a été sacrée 7e
mondial et puis notre espoir national le
petit ou en vente one donc nous
assistons ici à une finale au sida d'un
très très bon cru et franchement je suis
ravi